عقبات كثيره تحيط بانشاء محكمه خاصه
بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا باتت غير
قادره على وضع الرئيس الروسيب لديمير
بوتين في قفص الاتهام الاتحاد الاوروبي
اقترح العمل على انشاء محكمه خاصه تدعمها
الامم المتحده لملاحقه ما اسمتها بالجرائم
الروسيه غير ان اسئله جديه تطرح حول جدول
مثل هذه المحكمه وما اذا كانت ستنتهي
بمحاكمه الكرملين او كبار المسؤولين
العسكريين وتتمثل الاولى العقبه في انشاء
مثل هذه المحكمه التي تتطلب دعما دوليا
لمقاضاه حرب تشنج في اوروبا اما تحدي
الثاني فيبرز في توقيف مشتبهم بهم حيث
تقتصر جريمه العدوان على كبار المسؤولين
في روسيا فيما من المرجحي ان يكون بوتن
وكبار المسؤولين في مامن من الاعتقال
والمحاكمه على الاقل اثناء وجودهم في
المنصب وربما حتى بعد ذلك تحت شعار